so that's at some point in the scramble
he's gonna
come and seek them out trying to
increase his
positional advantage okay
so what i'm going to do is stop posting
here
and look to get a frame go he goes
and uses his energy is to bring him to
the other side
he's coming on
you can add your knee bone to it
you can get some small bridges but
here you lost the line
and then this is going to be muscle
there's no different he's coming in
same frame
[Music]
same exact thing and he's going
over he goes
boom
because the arms on the outside it's
almost like tenshi naga so make sure
you're checking it
okay so boom boom
okay
so let all the failed techniques
this energy don't brace anymore
you need to come in and you need to
clear the line
this way
okay let's technique he braces he's
coming back in
you want him to come in so boom
let him in
exaggerate that for now oh
no oh
let him in
he's getting on and this one didn't work
okay i can't get out
it failed he braced he left the hook on
me
let go of the technique go dude
come around the technique okay
come on
okay
so his brace is what makes it work
come on that brace right there
that's what he's going to use to try to
get back on
use the brace go around it
okay we're just we're just somewhere in
the scramble
where i'm going on okay
he's going to do the techniques a little
fine
he's going to do the first technique
[Music]
and i'm going to keep as much as i can
okay
well let's say i keep more than i did
last time
so he goes one way of keeping more as he
does
than he did last time is is as he pushes
on me we tend to get tense
do you see and then you create a lever
for him that's what makes it work
so you have to use your eye key he goes
and you're just going to segment
you see okay but he's still got hip
pressure but still i can't go down okay
so again you do a yin tactic so i'm
gonna go around
it and then i'm back on
so i got to here i
go around instead of trying to push down
and muscle him
i go around it by lifting up i'm back on
and now i'm getting a good striking push
okay so
segment to take away the first lever
segment means you're gonna have to relax
okay then
you're going on pull this relax you get
it
just it dies right it just dies then go
around this pressure
by going up boom okay now
his hands will get stuck there
oftentimes when you do that
but maybe you don't want to give up that
center control
but you don't have any leverage right
now okay so
especially as i come up you're going to
you'll regain it and you'll get it again
okay
then go into the same technique over the
top go finish
it again you work out several little
skills
in segment
around you hunting
pinch
okay let's